bonjour à la planète il est 11 à 11
examen exactement j'ai eu peur que ça
juste oui parce que je suis un si vous
êtes faire des tonnes au canada vous
avez ajouté une heure de plus six
fuseaux horaires au canada
ça ferait l'objet d'une excellente sujet
des missions je vous présente les
invités de cette semaine nos animateurs
parce que vous êtes tous bien plus que
des animateurs il ya beaucoup de science
et c'est autour de la table ismaël ou
d'assez une guide avec nos bons jours il
a accepté notre invitation au pied levé
pratiquement la merci de l'invitation
tout d'abord vous êtes levés et puis
vous êtes salut qu'à une invitation
alors vous avez déjà fait l'émission
dans le passé l'été dès cet été cet été
ça c'était la version allégée maintenant
c'est la version lourde
je suis prête avec nous notre mère amis
anglophones ici international bonjour
moi bonjour toi bon retour de vacances
deux mois elle a fait la globe trotteuse
toujours on regarde les détails mais
bien sûr bon retour marie claude simard
a bien quelqu'un qui est absent
aujourd'hui c'est léo gimeno et oui qui
est un taux trop occupé pour s'occuper
des choses essentielles vous expliquer
l'informer de lourdes
la formule de l'émission louis je veux
tout savoir bon ce qui anime c'est que
l'animateur ouvre l'émission de lettres
d'option des gens on lit un peu et là on
continue c'est un programme qui est un
bon et quand on continue qu'est-ce qu'on
jusqu'à la fin oublié des détails vous
avez sauté quelques étapes 10 entre le
début puis la fin il manque des choses
marie-claude expliquez-lui la suite
maintenant
mais on va avoir un invité mystère et
puis on va voir un jeu multicolores mais
on va gagner des points qui décrit mais
c'est très éloigné tout ça que tout le
monde est gagnant de toute façon à et
c'est gratuit ça ne coûte rien au
contribuable c'est ce que je trouve
extraordinaire dans cette formule je
voulais vous demander donc de porter
votre attention vers cette vidéo 5
images qui va déterminer le sujet
démission aujourd'hui vous devinez le
permis qui devine remporte mon estime
voici premières images qui apparaît pour
tous à travers le monde
quel est le sujet de l'émission
aujourd'hui la grande nature les feux si
vous êtes dans la bonne direction
oui et nous c'est dans le domaine du
possible de ces démissions aujourd'hui
oui mais ce n'est pas tout à fait ça le
coyote
le colloque je veux dire vous voyez une
différence entre louise quelques yacht
vous évidemment pas bon c'est un
spécialiste c'est bien et oui il a
raison dès la troisième image il a
deviné c'est de colloques mais le coyote
en ville c'est un animal bien
particulier et ça fait jaser beaucoup
les québécois particulièrement depuis
une couple d'années parce qu'il ya de
plus en plus de curieux dans nos
banlieues maintenant il y en a au
centre-ville de montréal et on a un
invité qui va nous parler de sens ce
n'est pas un mystère c'est un
spécialiste de ces questions là
aujourd'hui qu'il ay s'en vient mais
avant de vous montrer d'aller vers les
détails je voulais vous montrer c'est un
petit reportage de radio canada
international non non non donnera du
réseau des informations c'est différent
c'est pas rci serbie donc à la
télévision de radio canada en janvier
dernier plein sont on regarde son
ensemble
la toile où c'est difficile à dire parce
que je vous dis que c'est à montréal
c'est une vidéo qui a été tournée par un
automobiliste dans le quartier saint
michel et la vidéo circule depuis hier
au l'animal a été aperçu quand même
assez gros et a été aperçu au coin du
boulevard saint michel et de la rue
champdoré et selon la ville de montréal
la cueillette est de plus en plus
présents en ville vous à pourrait très
bien en être il aurait élu domicile aux
alentours de l'ancienne carrière miron
la ville dit que le coyote s'est adapté
à son milieu de vie urbains vivent
surtout la nuit et se déplace aux abords
des autoroutes et des lignes de
transport d'électricité
si montréal ont été attaqués par un
coyote l'été dernier mais la ville
affirme qu'il ne faut pas s'en inquiéter
un trappeur capture les animaux propre
but waouh c'est quelque chose tout à
fait hier justement hier matin il y
avait l'ours noir qui se promenait dans
un centre ville d'ottawa
c'est vrai oui il se pensait retrouver à
la dernière can à idées comme ça va mais
quand même c'est les grandes à turquie
al'approche de nos vies ne va rien c'est
ça on sait les villes qui se rapproche
de grande nature
il vient de très bien vu lui bon pas
besoin de spécialistes cette semaine
musicale en or il faut un spécialiste
moi je vais te la campagne à quelqu'un
qui est venu à battre un coyote sur mon
terrain illégalement il ya deux ans je
portais pas un peu plus se faire entre
amis évidemment à la police emilie
bronze pas de progrès mais moi je
pensais que c'était un loup quand je les
ai aperçus d'ensanglanter comme ça dans
ma cour arrière et c'était un coyote moi
je suis une absolument quoi la
différence entre un coyote est un loup
ben à coyote c'est plus petit qu'un loup
déjà dans sa dans sa morphologie
ok et puis je crois ça je suis pas sûr
mais il faudrait peut-être confirmé les
loups sont pas seuls ce ne sont pas des
animaux solitaires donc un loup tout
seul dans en ville c'est peu probable
les coyotes sont plus solitaire que
lilou ici a quand même des meutes de
coyote on va voir ça avec le spécialiste
puisqu'on parle de question de savoir
vous êtes prêt pour le premier jeu ya
aujourd'hui un lien grand prix de
participation cette semaine à remporter
voici oui rien parce que c'est cool
c'est votre premier jeu de plus de corps
alors ses premiers jeux premier tour bon
pour 20 points d'accord le deuxième
c'est bon pour 30 points le dernier bon
50 points toujours une façon de serait
de se rattraper voici pour ceux cette
question là le floor faire jouer la
vidéo mais aux trois que j'appelle
coyotes en plein hiver et il venait me
dire que fait ce que yacht que fait ce
colloque
regardez la réponse pour vous là pour le
moment d'accord que fait ce que iott on
a enlevé le 100 parce qu'il ya des le ya
un être humain qui filme et qui fait des
gros juron que fait ce colloque
oui marc je pense qu'il joue la raison
et je dis ça c'est parce qu'un chien
quand un chien qui se couchent avec des
pertes comme ça c'était une façon de ça
veut dire dans le langage des canailles
est que je veux jouer c'est pas un mode
d'attaqué
j'avais un gros chien relais je pense
j'ai peut-être un coyote je ne sais pas
ismaël ça a du sens vous avez une autre
belle oui ça a du sens moi j'aurais
pensé peut-être peut-être il a faim il a
faim qu'est-ce qui vous faire croire ça
ben je sais pas un coyote qui s'approche
d'un humain c'est pour une raison
alors oui parce qu'une reconnaître
sauvage donc c'est un peu inhabituel
dira-t-on tout à fait il ya seulement un
mot beaucoup plus scientifique pour
décrire ce qui était inhabituel ici mais
votre version des faits c'est une bête
qui essaient de communiquer depuis
qu'ils le message passe pas d'accord oui
qu'est ce qu'il dit ben il dit
qu'est ce que vous faites là sur mon
chemin surmonter intense et vous alors
écoutez on va bien en studio plein de
caméras ici je pense qu'on va attribuer
no 20 points désolé ce côté il faut bien
être un bon perdre mais je pense que
vous avez tout à fait tous les deux
raison il le joue certainement qu'il
joue
oui mais il a faim et il vient chercher
la nourriture dans les mains de ceux de
ceux de cette personne qui se promène
comme ça en plein en plein en pleine
nature
pensant que cet homme-là passer de la
nourriture on a 10 points chacun vous
avez 20 points chacun
j'avais le savoir est ce qu est ce qu
est une bête
habitué à cet anneau de recevoir la
nourriture comme ça parce que sinon ça
laisse d'être dangereux quand même bien
que diriez-vous qu'on se tourne là notre
spécialiste
bonne idée on accumule les questions
intelligentes mais aucune réponse
équivalente
alors voici notre invité monsieur simon
cas de bouaké professeur au département
de psychologie et de neurobiologie non
pas d'êtres humains mais des
spécialistes des comportements des
canidés et l'état l'université de dar à
ausy pour ceux qui ne savent pas où ça
se trouve bien c'est sûr la grande carte
du canada au nouveau brunswick où est la
tête je cultivais du canada mme en
écosse distance d'halifax vous trouvez
vous allez m'aider beaucoup je suis
arrivé à bon d'accord 0km donc zéro
point à l'examen il ya d'autres il ya
plus qu'une université dans l'asie à
nouvelle écosse c'est un endroit il ya
beaucoup d'étudiants
je pensais beaucoup de gens qui vont à
halifax beaucoup de jeunes des cités des
marines
en fait c'est un peu une ville qui dans
la tradition de la nouvelle angleterre
donc que cette université et plusieurs
d'entre elles alors parmi toutes les
choses que vous avez entendu depuis le
début de l'émission pendant que vous
étiez cacher qu'est-ce que vous relever
dans ce qu'on a dit qu' juste et pas
tout à fait
eux c'est un peu tout est à peu près
juste
et puis en fait plus ou moins
premièrement nous ne sommes pas des
spécialistes évident c'est en fait c'est
dans l'ignorance
c'est vrai qu'il ya une grande
différence de taille entre l'île où les
coyotes et ça c'est probablement une des
rares une des erreurs des plus communes
des gens qui vont dire ici en nouvelle
écosse où d'ailleurs il n'ya pas du loup
j'ai vu un loup guerre je suis convaincu
que c'est un lieu où etc
ils m'envoient même des photos et puis
sans aucun doute cet accueil est en fait
les coyotes sont à peu près le tiers de
la taille d'un loup canadien du mois
alors il ya des variantes assez
intéressant dans les tailles de loups au
travers du monde par exemple au moyen
orient sur qui dans les balkans ccd
animant un peu plus petit mais sinon de
façon générale les coyotes est beaucoup
plus petit que lui
ensuite il y avait la question d'amour
que vous avez discuté brièvement en fait
les coyotes sont un peu moins société
loue mais généralement vont fermer des
couples monogames c'est à dire mal une
semaine et puis après le printemps ont
durant le printemps jusqu'à peu près au
milieu de l'otan ils vont former une
petite meute dans le sens qu'une meute
c'est une limite et familiale finalement
donc c'est papa maman et puis les
clôtures de l'aisne
donc ça fait partie de certains des
commentaires de sur lequel j'ajouterai
peut-être quelques nuances
ensuite sur la question est est ce que
c'est normal de les trouver dans les des
environnements urbains
oui et non disons que c'est quelque
chose qui se prépare depuis probablement
une soixantaine peut-être même une
centaine d'amis le colloque c'est pas
une espèce en fait de l'est
c'est seulement depuis peut-être les
années 40 ou 50 qu'on a réalisé que
cette espèce de l'ouest ont commencé à
se répandre dans l'est de l'amérique du
nord
et ça c'est fait oui à peu près dans les
années 40 50 ou nord et au sud des
grands
et c'est pour ça que maintenant on les
trouve au québec dans les maritimes puis
évidemment dans le nord-est des
etats-unis
quelle est la relation maintenant qui
existe entre le loup et le coyote est ce
que c'est des animaux qui se côtoient
qui partagent un même territoire
essentiellement les achats c'est ici
même du de la région du fleuve saint
laurent y en a plus ça n'existe plus les
loups mais est ce qu'il ya un lien entre
les deux oui et non alors encore une
fois c'est dans l'ignorance
liu le coyote et les quatre espèces de
chacals le dingo aussi ainsi que le
chien en passant sont tous partis d'un
genre zoologique qu'on appelle le genre
qu'à nice alors canis lupus canis la
transe et le nom du coyote et c'est ce
qui est intéressant dans ce groupe
l'oeil c'est assez rare en biologie
c'est qu'en fait toutes les espèces de
ce petit groupe d'à peu près c'est sous
cette espèce peuvent se reproduire entre
elles et non seulement ça mais vont être
fertile
donc on peut avoir ce qu'on appelle en
anglais un colloque c'est à dire un
chien coyote ou encore good un chez nous
pardon un call you do
on peut avoir toutes sortes d'hybrides
mais en principe les coyotes parce
qu'ils sont plus petits sont souvent
fait la croix du licol devons tout faire
en fait pour pour éviter les villes où
la même façon que les renards vont tout
faire pour éviter les coyotes donc en
principe autour des habitations humaines
on va retrouver les humains les renards
ou à la périphérie
ensuite les connaître ensuite les lieux
mais évidemment ce n'est qu'une règle
avec évidemment comme tout avec beaucoup
d'exceptions
donc il ya eu en fait une moue
cours des années et c'est pour ça que
maintenant les gens vont vous dire qu'on
a beaucoup dit brees au québec et dans
les maritimes
cependant lorsqu'on dit ça il faut
encore ajouter les nuances ce qu'ils
apprennent qu'on a sont à peu près et je
pars de collecte sont à peu près 10%
lou est à peu près aussi 10% chien c'est
pas des 50% 50% la copie est encore une
fois cette prédation là c'est fait il ya
quand même assez longtemps et c'est pas
quelque chose qui se produit très très
souvent et c'est dans des circonstances
bien particulières comme d'un parc
algonquin
en ontario par exemple que beaucoup de
cette habitation là s'est produite mais
généralement ces deux espèces qui vont
se tenir loin de l'autre mc ismaël vous
avez aussi des questions pour notre
invité cette semaine par rapport aux
coyotes
d'abord c'était les questions du
vidéaste hybridation parce que ça
devient problématique parce que le monde
c'est les deux
comment dire attitude des deux animaux
sont différentes mais avec les hybrides
se pose plus de danger pour les êtres
humains et n'est ce pas en fait ça je
suis pas d'accord parce que je pense que
beaucoup de gens qui vont dire sans est
en fait le le coyote et est un de façon
naturellement et honeyman curieux mon
opinion et je suis pas le seul à dire
s'il ya d'autres experts qui vont dire
c'est qu'en fait si une inception de
loupe d'un coyote
ça devrait en fait de rendre plus timide
parce que lille où naturellement ont
tendance à devenir beaucoup plus loin
des humains que les coyotes
donc à mon avis ça ne rend pas le coyote
plus dangereux je serai peut-être plus
inquiets de l'inception chine dans le
colloque qui aussi se produire armes
mais il ya d'évidence génétique pour
démonter que ça c'est pas assez
encore une fois autour de 8 10% dans nos
rêves d'amérique mans donc en fait moi
je ne pense pas que c'est un mélange les
talents à réussir parce que ça a été
présenté comme ça à l'occasion avec les
médias mirkin surtout moi je trouve que
ces pauvres âmes à une raison alors en
fait il n'ya pas une différence de
taille très grand
une différences comportementales mais
relativement je dirais subtil dans le
sens que le coyote originellement c'est
une espèce de l'ouest comme j'ai
mentionné plus tôt mais aussi des
prairies on l'appelle d'ailleurs en
anglais le loup des prairies sauf que
avec l'hybridation avec les c'est une
espèce maintenant qui se sent un du tout
confortable dans milieu forestier
donc en fait salle izzo rendu encore
plus flexible est-ce que d' intéressant
c'est qu'ils lisent les coyotes c'est un
peu votre espèces typiques comme erreurs
des pigeons les humains de ce qu'on
appelle une espèce généralistes en
termes de diète d'habitants d'écologie
et ou qui s'adapte à peu près n'importe
quoi alors que lille où sont des
spécialistes
donc en fait moi je vois pas beaucoup
les brides à sion surtout pas à 10% avec
le loup comme étant vraiment un problème
dans ce sens que ça les rendrait plus
dangereux professeur avant votre arrivée
comme spécialiste à l'émission nous
avions un autre spécialiste de toutes
ces questions ismaël loin de là
évidemment il s'appelle vous avez une
question mais moi j'aimerais savoir est
ce que c'est un phénomène nouveau de
rencontrer des coyotes dans les villes
parce que évidemment n'en parle plus de
plus en plus donc soit c'est nouveau ça
on n'en parlait pas avancer quoi la
réponse est ce que tu les coyotes ont
toujours été en ville ou pas oui d'une
certaine façon oui et je vais encore une
fois nuancer tout seul parce qu'en
sciences en dit toujours ça dépend alors
voici en 2008
il savait peut-être c'est le match où
une jeune adulte ontarienne a été tués
ici par trois cas vers la
nouvelle-écosse aucun de temps en fait
depuis octobre 2008
c'était si je me rappelle bien 27 ou 28
octobre
et d'ailleurs je suis j'ai fait des
recherches sur ces call est là aucun
breton il semble que tout d'un coup le
coyote qui était plus ou moins ignoré
dans le passé est devenu une espèce
qu'on rapporte tout délit j'envoie un
coyote maintenant il appelle la police
s'ils appellent le département des
ressources naturelles etc etc alors que
avant 2008 n'ont plus qu'un renard pour
tous 40 ans là je pense qu'il s'est
développé
genre de syndrome autour du coyote à
cause de cette attaque l'homme qui
d'ailleurs en passant a été la première
attaque deux coyotes sont des éruptions
humain ça s'est jamais produit avant
sauf une fille est une adolescente très
jeunes adolescentes en fait en
californie je me rappelle bien au début
des années 80 mais c'est tout autrement
des coyotes n'attaquent pas les humains
de façon générale depuis ce temps là les
médias surtout se sont concentrées
beaucoup sur cet événement là et puis
maintenant on en parle c'est sexy de
parler des cueillettes envie de tout
mais encore jamais ni nuance est ce que
c'est possible qu'il y ait plus de
présence de coyotes amis du urbain ou en
banlieue même dans les vingt et trente
dernières années
oui il ya des évidences qui suggère qu
peut-être un peu plus pourquoi c'est une
bonne question
un des invités je pense mentionné moment
tonique en fait on s'avance dans l'ombre
du naturel d'une certaine façon c'est
une partie de la réponse
c'est pas nécessairement toute
l'histoire qu'est ce qui les amène dans
les villes mais encore une fois c'est
leur kabylité de ses victimes de
s'habituer à peu près de ce pardon de
s'accoutumer à peu près à tous leur
grande flexibilité comportementale je
pense qu'ils ont rapidement compris que
dans les villes ou dans les banlieues
ils peuvent facilement trouver de la
nourriture parfois hélas ils sont
nourris par les humains aussi et ils se
sont rendus compte que voilà l'occasion
ont pu ramasser le choc est tout seul ou
les tout petits chiens qui quitte une
proie facile en fait est là et ça
évidemment les médias par beaucoup
beaucoup de ces événements là est ce
qu'il ya une grande augmentation de ces
événements là moi je croyais que louis
jusqu'à ce que je voie les données de
parcs canada par exemple qui suggère qu
en fait dans les trente dernières années
il ya eu quand même un assez grand
nombre d interaction négative entre
coyotes et les animaux familiers ou
caillou des humains mais que c'est pas
nécessairement c'est pas à monter
exponentielle c'est pas aussi dramatique
comprend professeurs on va montrer des
images qui ont été captées ici à
montréal
les photos de photographies dans les
différents grands médias qui nous donne
ici une idée des affiches qui sont
maintenant visibles de ceux qui se
promènent dans les parcs municipaux on
le recommande d'être vigilant on voit à
l'écran ce moment pendant des conseils
coiffure hair quand une bête à un coyote
approche de nous donc c'est maintenant
quelque chose qui n'existait pas il ya
quelques années
est-ce que la campagne pour essayer de
le contrer le problème de présence des
coyotes
est ce qu'elle vise juste est ce qu on
sait ce qu'on fait parce que vous êtes
plein de nuances et on le sent c'est pas
évident c'est vrai que la nature bien
sûr soude encore une fois dans ce cas ci
est ce que ces campagnes vie jusqu'au
bout nous on pourrait faire autre chose
écoutez moi mon expert jusqu'à
maintenant avec les coyotes
enfin urbain j'ai pas vraiment
travailler halifax parce qu'on en a pas
tellement ce terme dans ma kou issi mais
s'était surtout illustré dans le village
de l'île du cap breton et aussi dans
l'île de permettre national des auteurs
mais une chose que je peux vous dire
c'est que presque toujours la source du
problème c'est la présence de nourriture
que ce soit nourrissage direct par les
humains ou indirecte des poubelles qu'on
laisse d'été des containers de poubelles
qui sont pas bien sécurisé beaucoup dans
les cours d'école c'est un peu ironique
comme situation mais souvent les
poubelles sont pas très bien sécurisé
alors l'idée [ __ ] laveur les des
renards sait pas qu'il ya des ours mais
dans certains cas comme on parle de
celui de l'or noir
ottawa c'est en fait toutes ces espèces
qui sont souvent très opportuniste mais
évidemment encore une fois à cause des
événements des 20 dernières années
lorsque c'est un coyote il ya un genre
de panique moi je pense que quelque
chose de très culturel aussi dans cette
peur naturelle qu'on a pour les canines
et le loup de coyote le coyote
maintenance un peu notre nouveau dans
notre mythologie moderne
si vous voulez mais de nourrissage c'est
beaucoup à la base de tout ça maintenant
est-ce que les tuer
les trappes et etc
est une solution non je crois jusqu'à
maintenant que la plupart des
gouvernements municipaux et provinciaux
ont visé juste
sauf quelques années en nouvelle écosse
où on avait un genre de debaty parce que
les données scientifiques nous démontre
très bien que les éliminer ce n'est pas
un concept
ils reviennent ils reviennent souvent
encore plus fort en plus grand nombre
donc je pense qu'en effet que ce soit
des coyotes ou d'autres espèces
il va falloir en effet apprendre à vivre
avec eux et faire la gestion de leur
présence et la gestion de nos poubelles
et surtout apprendre aux gens à ne pas
l'ignorer que ce soit directement ou
indirectement
si vous avez un promis dans votre dans
votre dans votre cour ramasser les
pommes à l'automne l'essai n'est pas au
sol parce que les coyotes vont aller
manger des pommes c'est toutes sortes de
petits détails comme ça qui compte
après un certain âge et les pommiers la
maison fox vous faire travailler cette
semaine j'ai vu ça ça tombe ça tombe
bien dernière question ici pour
professeur quatre bons au tour de table
marie-claude vous êtes très occupé à la
technique est simplement que vous êtes
impliqué dans un hlm sont toutes là j'ai
déjà je suis déjà demeurer dans l'ouest
de l'île de montréal près de l'île
bizard en fait
et puis même avant 2008
y'a déjà bizarre parce qu'on nous je
travaillais dans un hebdomadaire à
l'époque
et puis souvent on avait des appels de
deux résidents qu'ils disaient qu'ils
avaient vu déjà c'était quand même un
sujet médiatique je comprends que ça a
pris de l'ampleur quand il ya eu le
drame en nouvelle écosse
et
disons que moi je trouve personnellement
ça fait longtemps que je traite ces
sujets là non ça fait longtemps que je
dis que c'est de nouveau loué c'est ça
ben écoutez est ce que est ce qu'elle
dit quelque chose qui qui a du bon temps
oui bien sûr et tous ces événements
c'est très régionaux aussi au niveau des
villes qui n'ont qu'un problème de
coyote et en a d'autres qui en ont un
qui s'est pas développé encore mais qui
colmar août mois au général ça n'en fait
pas mention d'un coude au cas où en fait
qu'il y ait eu quoi il y avait une
présence de coyotes autres j'en ai vu
quand j'étais jeune
ce début des années 70 en fait et enfin
même seul en forêt il n'était pas
particulièrement intéressé à moi bien
sûr que la présence de ces animaux là à
l'île bizard ça ne surprend pas
terriblement la question c'est est-ce
que ça devient un problème
et lorsqu'on commence à avoir des
interactions négatives avec les humains
mais on fait quoi et c'est là que
justement les recommandations de faire
du harcèlement sont généralement les
bonnes parce que il ya deux temps de
l'année où on a des problèmes
typiquement au printemps lorsque maman
aux quelques gouttes ou antennes hier
qu'elle doit nourrir surtout si papa est
décédé ou est parti donc beaucoup de
travail avant de venir un peu paresseuse
parfois de le chef du voisin c'est une
proie facile à ce moment là et à ce
temps ci de l'année où ça commence parce
qu'on a les jeunes coyotes adolescents
qui commence à explorer un peu la chasse
qu'est-ce-qui facile à attraper
qu'est-ce que je pense qu'il l'a qu'ils
apprennent aussi souvent à ne pas
craindre
bisous mais c'est pour ça que les
cabanes d'harcèlement où on essaie de
leur faire peur ou en anglais on dit en
grade qui est un bon principe en fait
sont vraiment très utile parce qu'on
peut leur apprendre acquérir finalement
la peur de l'humain et c'est beaucoup
plus efficace que des campagnes
d'élimination professeur merci beaucoup
d'avoir enterré la science ici à
l'émission tracé précis j'en alors ici
les nuances c'est alors écoutez nous
c'est pas la première fois que on se
fait dire qu'il faut nuancer mais c'est
là c'était la place pour le faire
aujourd'hui infinie un grand merci
nous avons accompagné aujourd'hui à
l'émission merci merci beaucoup
alors c'était le professeur simon
gadbois qui est à halifax en nouvelle
écosse et tafer universités qui
s'appelle d'al haouz ou d'arroser une
spéciale de l'alimentation que l'on
parle à toutes les applis moi qui ai
deux là ont connaît assez bien cette
région 1
donc c'est un spécialiste des
comportements des canidés monde une
jeune auteure petite histoire de
raconter j'ai j'achète le blé d'inde de
nos fermiers et dernièrement de famille
et il ya une gamme de coyote qui
viennent dans son champ manger le blé
d'inde ils ont appris à manger le blé
d'inde de [ __ ] c'est problématique parce
qu'ils aient dit les cagnottes montre à
ces antiques baby boom de manger aussi
le bled ça fait peu de dégâts depuis
janvier
c'est mieux que manger le chat du voisin
vu que ça c'est des histoires comme ça
la main oui les petits chiens qui se
promène dans les parcs sans laisse ils
vont peser
ils font pas long feu moi c'est les
chats qui me font de la peine ils
peuvent penser à mon chemin
oui je me sers victime d'un coyote ce
serait triste qu'un train très graves et
que nous avons pas parlé des champs dans
une émission spéciale sur et qu'on avait
beaucoup de choses à dire à vos bientôt
vous en faites pas écouter pour
l'halloween
ça serait bien qu'on parle d'elle ou
s'ils n'ont écouté deuxième bug pasqua
cette émission c'est bien sûr donc le
jeu de grosses boules deuxième tour
c'est bon pour trois points c'est très
facile la réponse j'accepte même les
mêmes réponses est bon 30 points on lise
on les donne aujourd'hui que qu'est ce
qu'on fait lorsqu'on rencontre cote il
faut faire quoi
quand on rencontre un coyote quelque
part que si j'ai bien compris il faut
lui faire peur findus erreur ok quand me
dise ce temps je regarde ce qui s'est
passé je ne bouge pas vous me fait pas
peur mais je vais vous faire par moi
j'en ai vu réalité nous rattrape certain
que je vais avoir l'instinct de
déguerpir c'est à dire prendre les
jambes à mon cou puis peut-être un recul
en par contre il va vous courez après
département mignon alors écoutez qui
avec 20 points lors de la première
manche entre les deux on n'a pas partagé
alors
à cordes et voix encore 30 points si
vous avez 50 chacun question on va aller
sur lol est ce qu'on a le thé les
missions de préparation technique de
cette émission tout à fait
et si on va dans une chronique d'une ça
s'appelle fouiller dans nos archives
c'est sur la page de tam-tam cette
semaine voyez il ya différents sujets
non pas ça ça c'est nos meilleurs notre
meilleur cette semaine en principe se
juge pas seulement pas oublié on va
aller en voilà c'est là découvrez nos
archives sur le même sujet donc vous
voulez compléter l'information
dc merci des coyotes
avant l'arrivée bien sûr qu'un des aides
peut pas besoin de lunettes pour voir ça
j'espère nous loue canadien quoi père
baird du poil à cause des coyotes
bon écoute et ont envie de lire tout ça
vous irait dire ça on est prêts pauvres
jeunes est juste est-ce qu'ils eurent
comme des doux ou je ne sais pas on a dû
demander une bonne question et je
l'appelle d'appel on pourrait on
pourrait vous êtes fou fou c'est à dire
comme on dit c'est hurler ewell ou hurle
c'est vrai oui ou non c'est la chouette
qui hulule qu il va pas nous aimer
donner 1000 $ pour une apparition
aujourd'hui je mets vins qu'on aime
c'est gratuit tout est gratuit
faut pas nous croire que c'est la
première fois qu'on fait ça oui c'est ça
bon quel dommage pour ce qu on se
reprendra
c'est alors continuez vos recherches
dans la grande si politique canadienne
de radio canada international peut-être
à suivre oui c'est ça prêts pour le
dernier jeu de la grosse boule
oui très bien alors pour ce dernier jeu
il faut absolument regarder la vidéo
d'accord ta vidéo que je vous présente à
l'instinct numéro 7
la numéro chance c'est une belle chance
ça c'est tout tu te reconnaître quelque
chose avec peu de son way avec chance
avec un peu de chance
ça vous rappelle des souvenirs
j'habitais aux états unis je regardais
ça la télévision américaine
mais j'ai découvert x est arrivé un peu
plus tard dans la francophonie
en france dans les années 90 au québec
dans les années 2000 c'était à télétoon
tel qu'ils l'ont vu en avant un autre
shy'm et cd classique 1 ça dure environ
six minutes transportées l'enclume sur
une corde tendue dont la version
française turbine 3 parker alors on a eu
l'autorisation de warner brothers de
vous présenter ça aujourd'hui je vous
dis c'est youtube s'est chargé la
négociation ça coûte rien voici la
question
indémodable van beek bip et coyote ça se
casse en france d'accord en anglais
s'appelle bronner and what i call if i
call you t il faut faire la traque de
produits et ont baissé parce que c'est
un jeu de mots aussi pour les
francophones il faut dire que c'est un
jeu de mots sur le mot actuel wali qui
se veut dire rusé d'écolière celui ci
n'est ce pas c'est que son hélico le
renard bon beaucoup de spécialistes à
cette édition
trop de ce pc alors voici la série
animée elle comporte combien d'épisodes
on les voit souvent là combien en dieu
moi je vous aurais
mille six cent mille six cent celui qui
le plus proche de la bonne réponse
encore des 50 points doctorat qu'une
bonne claque une personne gagnant de 16
500 pages il y en a pas tant que ça
n'est pas tant que ça j'imagine
parce qu'il remettait ça en boucle mais
ça fait plusieurs années aussi anglais
c'est vrai ça fonctionne et que vous
regardez ses 250 j'aurais dit cent
cinquante 150 pierre notre technicien
bon salaire d'une question de cacher oui
trois cent 300 désolé on vous a entendu
je pense que permet à l'émission
non c'est juste nous qui vous avons pas
d'accord donc c'était de la bonne
réponse est non non ok il a dit roy
j'amènerai pensée des hommes ça
évidemment je vais être sur la bonne
réponse moi 1249 c'est pas la bonne
réponse
c'était le début de la série 45 épisodes
savais qu'il y avait pas tant que ça
alors qui a qui remportent des 50 points
et moi qui ait le maximum du total
possible sans bon sens mais c'est la
chance dur mais c'est drôle parce que ça
fait des années et des années qu'on
regarde sa vie normale des choses après
se voir vu ça depuis des années à temps
a tout vu les 45
oui il remettait en boucle c'est ça le
vrai très oui c'est la magie de la
télévision
nous ça nous prend une émission de
nouvelles chaque semaine ça va bien pas
pouvoir faire ce n'est pas bon et c'est
tout à fait je pourrais vous présenter
autre chose mais j'ai peur on essaie de
rappeler oui
d'accord que il m'a demandé si on
l'avait rappelée à c'est fantastique ça
il vous a demandé ça sur skype
ouais on se parle aussi jeune et ça
c'était son petit ami vous n'avez pas
encore non chanter une petite chanson
tellement d'initiative reconnaît des
chansons dont on parle de louer ou de
coyote
ou dans les mots
hu a tandis que le loup n'y est pas
c'est le loup y était il nous mangerait
jeu de la garderie un loup oui tu étais
tu quand je mets ma chemise
ça rappelle des souvenirs ouais des
mauvaises bon écoute et on va être sans
réponse c'est bon alors on va hurler
euh c'est quoi la chanson l'esthète
populaire roselyne pas d'anglais ici à
finition s'il vous plaît écoutez ismaël
merci beaucoup d'air si vraiment un
plaisir je suis fini des jeux peuvent
quand même vous invitez entre ce que
vous avez combattu fièrement mais perdre
la guerre il n'y a que des gagnants on
avait dit au début de l'année 6 1 puis
marie-claude essaie de convaincre votre
collègue des eaux de venir à venir un
projet difficile je crois que j'avais
art de vous retrouver parce qu'eux on
avez vous obtenu elle ment des gens on a
parlé de l'équipe de rêve
ouais vous étiez la moitié des bus cette
équipe de rêve alors voilà c'est tout
pour cette semaine à quelques caméras
ont dit au revoir à la semaine prochains
mois au revoir